ladies and gentlemen this is only our
third episode and I'm told the show is
already a hit so from the bottom of my
heart thank you and this week we have
the most famous doctor on the planet dr.
Drew Pinsky
he not only organized my intervention
with johnny Knoxville he was running the
whole rehab where I went to get sober
I've known him for almost 20 years he
has seen me at my absolute worst treated
me as a patient and he knows me
absolutely as well as any famous person
I can think of this is such an honor and
it's actually the first full-length
podcast we recorded we did this in the
van I was renting to decide if I wanted
to buy a Motorhome and the experience
was so overwhelmingly positive I knew I
was gonna go for it
I've been saving this one because it's
special and it's so intense I'd share
with dr. Drew what my most dire health
concerns are like where my body is most
banged up and then we get into it so
really enjoy this one because it's a
treat ladies and gentlemen dr. drew
everybody dr. drew am i first
you are this is the best I'm so happy
I'm so excited I'm so happy for you it's
legitimately the first try at a full
length fantastic deal yeah it's good
we're not we're not gonna edit anything
yeah but yes so we rent it is that those
perfectionism going on now we've got to
get going no that wasn't always the case
oh my god you should have heard me when
I used to be a guest on Loveline with
drew before I got sober I wouldn't call
that perfectionism really I can't
believe that dr. drew welcomed me on the
love line with him so often when I was
such an insufferable man well we didn't
know how bad things were at the
beginning right and either you really
not
maybe you did and when it became clear
that this was not going well you always
said and you were super clear about it
when it comes time for me because I kept
bugging you oh man come on you got to do
something right basically screw you when
I do this I'll know and I will do it for
real I'll do it all in I remember you
had a program about like quitting
smoking and I told you that I would
smoke cigarettes with a fake long
through a hole in my throat
I'd be the he'd be the tracheostomy
right voice box
do you have guests come on that like you
know it's like you know what drugs are
on but they're like kind of hiding it I
can be biessed by the best of you know
but but I kinda have a hint
well it's opiates are really easy right
it's really grabbing on and Matt meth is
pretty easy but people combine stuff and
then it gets a little confusing where
were you on when you went on there I
used to go out to the bathroom to do
cocaine I'd have cocaine Briggs mostly
like just weed when I was doing the
radio with Drew but yeah okay so we've
been prepared with questions my first
one because it's really before you go to
it just probably got going on here
this is we're in a van I've rented it to
see if it works cameras all over the
place so far it really feels like it
does work I mean you probably have done
the most like podcasts out of anybody
out there Corolla he's that more I'm
sure okay good okay I've done a lot and
I right yeah and I've ever when this all
started happening steve steevo is like
Steve like god damn who's gonna ask me
to do another podcast right I saw that
that if I haven't heard of the podcast
the answer's no and I don't think I
never you know it's it's fun it's a way
to socialize with people you see people
yeah I mean for a while and it makes
sure you connect with people I mean it's
kind of a weird inside it's a crazy
thing yeah so I mean I've got a number
of questions the first one
I think I'm gonna go with is I know that
there are like dr. oz dr. Phil and
they're not really doctors okay buzz was
the head of cardiovascular surgery right
but does he continue to have a medical
practice he was operating until a couple
years ago I don't know what he's doing
now I haven't talked to it so celebrity
doctors who maintain a practice as you
do and I think most people don't know
that you do most people don't know that
you have an office and is there another
doctor with medical practice who's such
a household name as you are uh I don't
know it's hard to judge that kind of
thing however like what's the guy that
anchors the doctors he's pretty well
known and he's a ER doc we don't know
his name anchors the doctors that the
talk show the doctors on there yes oh
yeah they're normally going through
something when they get a face tattoo
like that you know it's so true I wish
like Tyson would talk about that because
I think he could talk about it pretty
vividly what he was going through when
he got his face tattoo was he in prison
when he got it no I don't think so
okay what I see it as to me it goes in
the same category as Britney Spears
shaving her head it's it's and clothing
you went you zoom past that into driving
a motorcycle off the building I'm now
thinking about getting a face tattoo
why but just because like people who
have face tattoos seem to be really rich
I was thinking about getting a dick
shaped teardrop tattoo but now I'm
thinking about having the dick kind of
go over my eyebrow I know
or man what you put him through yeah we
were gonna do that after the anesthesia
bit that we were talking to you about oh
yeah that under I told Dad though that
it's really just for the purpose of
finding out how long I can last with the
dick on my face before I go rushing to
go get later lasered off oh that's
interesting
yeah I think the forehead is good
because some people call you [ __ ]
okay but so hold on so so we got
off-track here so when I see people
impulsively dude shave their head like
when you were super manic did you have
an impulse to shave your head there was
a time when I wanted to get PCP saved my
life tattooed around my neck right neck
head neck impulse like do something is
sort of a manic thing why they face I
don't know it's just you know people do
things in certain states it's just were
primates and whatever and they're
getting these altered states certain
behaviors emerge and this one I just I
just see it all the time as a manic
thing right most importantly Scott we've
established that for our first guest we
have the most famous doctor on the
planet that's all that matters it's a
real gay I happened to be Bros with dr.
drew no big deal right now as a real
true personal concern we hear Joe Rogan
talking about it a lot he says it's a
no-brainer that anybody over the age of
40 should be taking testosterone
replacement therapy I don't disagree
with him strongly okay I can't I have
prostate cancer I would love to and and
I and I bust my physicians balls all the
time about it I'm like like when I went
in for my operation I'm like first thing
I want you know is if I'm five years out
remission you're putting me on
testosterone really yeah of course now
I've got a problem and I probably need
some radiation or whatever you said I
have it it's not I had it and but
because of that little
[ __ ] mark I can't do it but I was I was
head of physical the other day and that
doctor I was busting his balls going two
years out after ad yeah yeah do you have
to do it for life
TRT he once you start I am I was around
when the Women's Health Initiative study
came out which condemned estrogen
therapy for women it was a flawed study
for a number of reasons and I had prior
to that seen the benefits of estrogen
and progesterone therapy it was
remarkable how much better people's
quality help the layman here with women
on hormone replacement at but why would
they be taking it because their ovaries
shut down menopause okay so we used to
routinely put people on therapy and I
noticed that their cognition was better
their quality the strength everything
with bone density they seemed in my
estimation have less heart disease then
this whi came out this Women's Health
Initiative came out and said no more
heart disease more strokes more dementia
more breast cancer yeah get it off and I
took them all off and they literally we
were told you are a witch doctor if
you're doing if you're not following the
priests the findings of this study well
we all took him off women miserable
horrible and I started slipping people
back on again because it was so bad
great and lo and behold it turns out the
study was deeply flawed so I saw the
benefits across my career of hormone
replacement therapy it always made sense
to me why shouldn't men have a benefit
to our testosterone starts falling off
right now that I'm of a certain age I
categorically know I'd be better with it
that tell you that fatigue the way I
know I weight stuff is just the way I
work out I join everything fatigue
stamina
oh that's just not the same and I and I
know I know and and by the way I use
androgen blockade which is testosterone
blocking agents in treating prostate
cancer and I see what happens to men
when you do that it's not pretty
they get dimensions and things sometimes
I know I would is that one like all your
hair falls off your body and come by dad
had it he did that he did the treatment
with laser down la jolla the prostate
cancer yeah then he took a hormone
blocker also yeah and he said he D game
was shot blueprint he said he was just
kind of like crying on the couch
you know yeah III I like I said I was
good my doctors and I start pushing I'm
I go look it because we were talking
about whether I need radiation there per
say well here's one thing if I need and
you're blockade I'm not taking the
certain medication I know will happen to
me and they're like nothing to stop it
it's not gonna happen
don't worry about is there any such
subject that the scientific and medical
community cannot like twist and disagree
like no matter what she seems
yes I particularly clinical because
biology infinitely complex infinitely so
to try to make sweeping absolutes about
the human biology I got full pretty
upset with I think I even emailed you
about it with like the way the animal
activists people like will twist all
these all the science to tell you things
that aren't necessarily true right it
saves a lot it happens a lot yes there's
another story I don't think you know
Scott were Steve in using had a heart
problem are we thought he had a heart
problem
yeah that like yeah this is what
happened in England no no dad was in
England my I was I was prior to sobriety
I was just and prior for really
escalating the addiction to you were
drinking a lot that I was I was because
that's what I don't did that I was okay
with the drinkin it was specifically
2006 when we were filming jackass number
two and I had made a promise to Spike
Jonze and Knoxville and Jeff Tremaine
that I would not do cocaine for the
whole duration that movie I somehow it
kept the promise right right said I
would it's exactly like a fountain if
you like to suppress one thing they all
shoot higher right so I just was I was
just like the worst with alcohol and
this thing yeah and I was just temper
temper temper tantrum City and I was
just not lovely
and my family was giving me a lot of
grief about it he was
but he wasn't lovely right and I you had
told me about this executive health
program at UCLA and I said look you know
dad and sister my whole family I said
look you guys I'm gonna go to this
executive health thing which is worrying
about your health around that no I was
only worried about my family on my back
because I knew there's some some Lori
coming through my back I thought it was
your words they'd have to stop using
drugs and alcohol you'd have to do that
I wasn't worried in the slightest about
anything but I had pretty like good
confidence that my health wasn't
terrible okay despite all of the you
know the substance abuse and you had
told me about this program which was so
my comprehensive comprehensive so much
so that is not even covered by health
insurance because they're there they're
like you know you don't even need all of
this medical attention so I said guys
I'm gonna pay for it I'm gonna go in
there and I'm gonna get this fully
comprehensive physical and if I come
back healthy then you just leave me
alone just off my back and that's the
deal
ladies and gentlemen you know this story
is gonna be dope but let me tell you
that as uncomfortable as I was doing
this for the first time I think that
this is the best podcast we've done so
far and now I'm totally comfortable
especially because this week the show is
sponsored by Mack Weldon who makes the
most comfortable highest-quality boxers
briefs sweat pants sweat shirts socks
hoodies and I'm telling you that they
hook people up because they value
loyalty so much they created the Mack
Weldon blue program which means that if
you sign up for an account which is free
to do then you never pay for shipping
again and then once you've spent $200
then all of a sudden you get free
shipping plus 20% off of your orders for
the next year now if you go to Mack
Weldon calm and enter the promo code
steve-o just for nothing you get 20% off
your first order but you'd be crazy not
to join the Weldon blue program and I'm
telling you I
promote stuff unless I use it and I love
it
and let me show you how much I love
these sweatpants as I take them off and
these boxers as I fling my garbage back
and forth and then catch it in the back
with a hands-free mangina tuck that is
courtesy of Mac Weldon thank you guys
for making such fantastic stuff and
making buying it such a treat online I
mean really it's the easiest most fun
website to go to hassle free and thank
you for taking such good care of us now
back to the show so I went and I did
come I was so worried about an STD test
I was like man they the doctor called me
to come in to get the results and I'm
like oh no you know that's terrible news
so I come in to get the results and the
worst doctor I've ever seen he called me
into the office and I thought oh my god
terrible news and I walked in as a
doctor is my wiener okay like I said is
it my where is my wiener okay and he
says your wieners fine but it's your
heart like an 80 year old man he said
the heart of like an 80 year old man and
and there's zero chance that you're
gonna live to see the age of 40 and
unless you stop drinking
oh good he's zeroed on that that was a
woman that told you I think I remember
it being a dude and I was like he said
you have no chance of seeing the age of
40 unless you stop drinking now you told
me of the alcohol thing cuz I brought up
the alcohol thing as I remember I never
thought I was gonna see the age of 40
anyway and I told this guy I said I said
who cares
I said who cares it's not my wiener you
know I cared who cares about my heart
but then like that night I was a guest
dude started talking to you about this
look it was based on an echocardiogram
which is not the way to assess
accurately this issue he should have
said we need you to do some more studies
to see if this is real before he starts
talking
he told me I had cardiomyopathy and that
he needed a transplant no I didn't see
it transplant said I needed to stop
drinking it's a no we're talking me
about transplant maybe I have a chance
at our members because that that
disturbed the hell I don't remember a
talk about a transplant I just remember
that jumping all way to transmit I by
God the heart of an eight year old man
you need a transplant I'm pretty sure
that transplant was not part of the
discussion started drinking I completely
understood he said I had to stop
drinking I were you drinking it they at
this point I mean enough to get drunk I
was drinking like vodka redbull he was
hard all day oh you were doing vodka
redbulls all day try me in pretty much I
know but I'm bad like I so I went on
Loveline with dr. Drew I think that
night yes it was that night that night
and I was like dude it was like like the
doctor told me I'm dying man like I'm
dying and like and dr. Drew was just
totally just aghast at all these callers
here and yes the colors were like
literally every caller was like hey
steve-o sorry about your heart anyway
about my wiener and it made me realize I
think we talked about this that they
were treating him like a cartoon
character they didn't seem as a person I
thought cartoon Kirti I think there was
there was a lot of like oh dude you'll
be fine man you're gnarly like it's like
the video that he did where he's
bleeding out of his boxer shorts and
important fake blood in my boxer shorts
and then I went and people are asking
that was deeply troubling yeah you took
it a good stride yeah it was a bit bad
but I think after talking with you that
night the whole thing it kind of sunk in
I was like man I gotta I gotta stop
drinking I still had doubts that it was
real I really I was right I thought to
myself you know their prize what I was
I thought he's drinks enough to get a
little card in my up with thee it can be
a reverse yeah he can reverse he needs
to stop drinking let's let him let's let
him get that let that sink in hey well
let that sink it and let's stop talking
about this being an end-of-life thing
because I really didn't believe it I did
right all right what so I got I went to
the airport like maybe the next day or
something I was just like I gotta stop
drinking so my best thing it was the
first time I'd ever bought a first-class
ticket in my life I just showed up the
airport and I said can please get me a
first-class seat on the next flight to
England so I could go eat pickled onion
monstermunch because if I couldn't have
alcohol like this like this absurd baked
corn snack that's why I went to London
and then with your family you don't
think maybe you wanted them and yeah I
mean I was you know I was a wacky dude
at the time that's crazy and would you
have at other organs I was gonna say
what what organs from like drug users
like drinking or smoking can can repair
themselves and cannot repair themselves
after you quit it's pretty complicated I
mean depends what you have to go with
the heart we'd have to go through every
drug in every organ oh really
let me ask a more basic question I
remember being told that 95 percent of
alcoholics / addicts will die loaded of
causes related directly to drugs and
alcohol is that accurate
if they're not treated yeah that's
pretty close okay real true addict yeah
and how do they know these stats though
because cause of death alcoholic liver
disease apathy stroke you'll be doing
cocaine and kidney disease I was just
boom yeah and by the way the coroner's
screwed up all the time actually really
pisses me off
they don't understand addiction in the
corners they really don't and so they
just I don't know she just she she acts
it I argued with Yamaguchi you know the
guys did like he did everybody he did
Marilyn Monroe and in Natalie Wood and
and John Belushi he had the temerity to
go jump Lucia was a drug
what are you talking about oh just
someone would give my heart to give me
just that night happen to give him
something say he was an addict like what
he signed him off as like not related to
drug addiction the final cause of death
for John Belushi speedballs wish winter
ever since called Belushi's I've seen
this again and again and they still to
this day happens where the pathologist
because they're not clinicians they're
pathologists you know they get off the
clinical track very early and they just
don't understand what they're looking at
here okay so I need to get on
testosterone replacement therapy well
you say that I just said I'm in the Joe
Rogan camp enthusiasm for it but it
needs to be done very carefully I you
know Mike Catherwood my love line part
yeah he's very involved with some guy in
Venice that apparently is an
endocrinologist and does this stuff we
can go see somebody really can do it
carefully and once you start assuming
that you do start then you can never
stop what you can stop but you're gonna
lose all the effects and something it
only has the benefits when you're taking
two people's heads get bigger
is that like like Mark McGwire Barry
Bonds like that was that was extra
physiologic so so ideally you want to
just restore testosterone to so to boost
it a little bit the level closer to your
youthful time and not give you high
levels of and then you've dated
androgenic an anabolic and they did a
bunch of yeah that way and that and that
it makes your enlarges your product
product lanza stuff yeah um so in TNT's
that steroids it's a steroid
I mean TRT is testosterone replacement
therapy right trt and the the backbone
of testosterone is a steroid molecule so
yeah so it's an androgenic steroid
1cc a week is pretty good this is
something you gotta talk somebody looks
normally good and they're over 40's Joe
I'm sure ask Joe I'm sure he sees it
everywhere yeah you can tell people are
doing it right I believe it
okay so it's become kind of my
Catherwood god damn him well you know
because he knows I can't take
testosterone eat sorry go go take
androgen just take just take anabolic
steroids Oh his physique is something
else these days I'm wondering he is
gorgeous too
so I saw on TMZ that you were singing
opera like at a hockey game isn't me the
national anthem as an opera singer well
that's how am I saying okay so it's
become kind of common knowledge that you
sing opera
well not that comic cuz then I did the
masked singer and they nobody got it
until until I had to pull the head off
okay
do people ask you to sing a lot and
we've got an accompanying up for you we
want to rehearse five minutes before we
go out there that I'll do that do you
love it
Mike singing no not anymore so when I
did the masked singer I started really
training again and I've lost a whole
range of stuff I used to have so I kind
of pisses me off action
I do like singing but I had a pretty
powerful voice at one time and you if I
want to start that would all come back
Wow so yes and I had all kinds of
problems in the mess a devil in Grasse
to being stuff they did look at my
chords I had hemorrhaged on my cord and
a pharisee on my course because I could
tell something was mechanically wrong
because when I started training for real
I was like oh this just it's just the
whole range was just gone so I'd have a
focal rehab it's there corticosteroids
and things - how long ago was that
July Oh recently the men's thing you
know Joe I'm not familiar with the
master a lot of you I promise you people
are they're ridiculous okay yeah it's
like it's like Dancing with the Stars
kind of okay so it's like unlikely a
singing talent from people yeah well but
then yes that sort of one that conceits
the other is
real singers like I got beat up by Patti
LaBelle okay dressed as a giant
how old is Patti LaBelle she's older she
sang pretty well okay um okay guys I've
got a couple serious questions here like
we're men and recovery talk to us about
the CBD [ __ ] like if it's like a yeah
topical CBD fine right okay Tom I'd then
I've done like a roll thing on my neck
or so yeah fine low dose should be fine
I worry about the higher dose tinctures
I worry about that
what's tincture the little drops under
your tongue oh yeah I don't want to put
anything in my mouth I had this one guy
telling me oh here's this take a picture
with the CBD water that I have and I was
like nah man I just weirded out by that
it's like man it's not psychoactive and
I was like dude I just don't I my wife
and I tried it we took probably a 50
milligram something like that relatively
small dose everything in the pantry had
the best sex in here she got panic
attacks the next day from it and my
sleep was all messed up oh my mom had
something with her knee and I thought it
was I thought it was just like a CB like
a CB d no THC yeah I think I gave her
the wrong one because it were her knee
pain went away but I said how did you
feel
and she's like well I don't know honey
like she never smoked pot anything like
that she's like I don't know honey like
I woke up and and I was just really
hungry and she took a picture of all the
snacks she was eating oh boy candy bars
chips diet cokes just like and she's
never eats like that oh yeah I just
dosed my mom baby but I I use it I
recommended people fairly frequently I
mean it's I mean like and that it's an
important question for me because I feel
like not as a result of injuries not as
a result of anything but I just feel
like in my elbow my shoulder like like
it's how I imagined carpal tunnel just I
feel it breaking out and my as we get
older you just get lots of eggs your
joints start to hurt and I remember
because we are the three of us we went
to South Africa and I was just
thing up my my carry-on bag to put it in
the overhead bin and all the sudden my
arm went right yeah and like ever since
then I cannot properly make a Popeye
muscle oh did you beat you tear you down
probably tore your and can you like can
feel I but here's the thing
we never stretch and so I think stretch
is a big part of that that's not
supposed to be there novio cyst here
feel here they're really common okay
yeah I had that comes off the wrist very
commonly yeah I had the funniest thing
happen this side like I can't even yeah
I think your tour part of the tendon
it's alright TRT over her shoulders go
to I know the shoulders are going to I'm
not sure you listeners want to hear all
I've been chipping away at it not not
all the way through it
three and a half hours yeah it's uh I'm
watching like small chunks at a time
would enjoy visually I dig it I I I
can't hurt me to watch those guys they
either look too old or not and there's a
tool most the time isn't it like CGI
they made Robert De Niro like way yeah
yeah but when he goes out and tries to
beat up that cop no no the shopkeeper
the shop yeah push body twenty-nine
there thirty or something yeah that's
the point and then when he's in the
nursing home
why is he - nursing home he looks way
too is they at the end they're gonna go
he's just a while yeah when I saw him
start on him as a young guy I thought he
was like in his late 50s
they're covering from like the sixties
all the way to like present-day right
but with all my joints starting to break
down like TRT will help and CBD topical
yeah
topical would be fine I just have a
problem because I'm worried about all
CBD because it didn't used to be legal
and then now it's like changing laws and
and as I'm telling you both my wife and
I had some brain effect I mean we didn't
get high from it or anything but we were
like affected by it a little bit so it's
not zero it's not zero and fine by the
way people are it's not psychoactive
it'll help your anxieties like people
smoking huge joints that don't get you
high CBD no smoking hemp and it's it's
like 0.01 THC so it's like pretty
non-existing what's the point and
they're like I just Mel's you out it's
like you're smoking cigar I'm like did I
used to love smoking weed like yeah yeah
yeah I couldn't you have to smoke so
much of it because then but yeah but
then I'd be like oh my god is this a
relapse and then I'd already start that
relapse I might as well to smoke weed
yeah I don't know don't do it the dog
definitely don't go down the track okay
speaking of relapse for people in
recovery is it true that the jobs with
the highest rate of relapse are
specifically jobs where people work in
recovery
I don't know that data but that would
not surprise me that would not surprise
me I had a lot of people go out right
I'm fine and in I would tell every time
so over the long period that I was
working in the field I came to the point
where I was insistent that if you're
working here you were going to al-anon
that's it because the ones who didn't go
to Ellen I would get taken out pretty
fast that in you know in pernicious ways
they'd have sex with patients and do use
with I just horrible ways and it's just
like
it gets you know the disease gets under
your skin right right somebody with it
is your once around so much of it it'll
get you okay start here's something that
I personally feel pretty strongly about
with regards to anonymity for people in
recovery you know I think that if we
look at the the origins of 12-step
programs the reason for anonymity was
that there were so few people that
started it if they were to put their
full names out there they would just be
swamped they could never handle it and
conduct normal lives and there's a lot
of shame associated with it right and
the yes so some of the prohibitions on
media was actually Bill W his wife it
was the 11th tradition was her idea and
she and towards the I think she's gone
now Louis yeah come reconsider that she
thought she thought no no it's important
now then we get out in the media and
talk about this really thank because
what she says about fourth looked under
you interview him well I do it in my
view anyway it was like they said that
in the book there's just too few of us
we got to keep ourselves anonymous
because we can't help everybody and then
now in this day and age that's clearly
not the case the recovery world is
thriving it's alive and well and now I
think the most common idea about why
anonymity is important people say well
if you wave the flag of sobriety and the
12-step program and then you end up
loaded people are gonna see that and
they're gonna think oh well hey doesn't
work you know 12-step has been under
attack for a while too well so here's
the thing I mean I equate that to
somebody getting in really great
physical shape you know shirt off
looking like Mike Catherwood just
shredded and like and then a year and
they give all the credit to save you
know 24-hour fitness oh it's the
greatest then a year later they're fat
slobs absolutely nobody is gonna start
thinking 24-hour fitness doesn't worry
did that right they're gonna be like oh
geez you stopped going a 24-hour fitness
exactly how they should think of it but
they they love to attack if you're not
sober for eternity it's 12 steps problem
but but I think that what's important
about anonymity is that when people
professionalize their sobriety correct
then inherently their motivation is
skewed correct
I think the 11th edition and the
anonymity is an attempt to make sure it
doesn't become something commoditized
something branded something of any
market forces on it at all no business
and so these are there was a very wise
move to let it be just an interpersonal
experience sure nothing more and to keep
it quiet to me is a way of a first of
all protect people who want to be that
way so and then be making sure people
aren't out the seeking power property
and prestige motion yeah promotion would
be a bad thing for this right yeah okay
um let me see we might we might need a
little bit of a okay now this is
important to you talk to us about the
the what we do about the homeless
situation ebonic plague oh my god let me
first talk about the 12-step thing real
quick there is a guy named John Kelly
that runs the Harvard addiction program
in a guy named Keith Humphries that runs
Stanford have are doing studies that's
showing the 12-step is as good or better
than any other treatment that's
professionalized out there especially if
abstinence is your goal this is as good
or better than anything else out there
and oh by the way it's free it's
available 24/7 it's on every corner oh
by the way you're worried about health
expense it's free it works stop
attacking it it needs to be part of
everything we talk about when we're
talking about the opiate crisis and all
these other problems we should be in the
next message going there's free services
out there that works it's evidence-based
take advantage of sure I mean the way I
look at it is that you know let's say 95
percent of alcoholics and addicts do die
loaded of causes related to drugs and
alcohol it's no mystery that the five
percent who do achieve long-term
long-term sobriety are locked arms that
we do it together yeah that's what the
whole thing is about I don't think it's
as low as 5% I we
that 95% number I think is if you
continue using you'll die of
consequences of your disease if you make
repeated attempts at sobriety there's a
very good probability like in the 50 60
% zone that you're gonna have sobriety
okay but if you have meaningful sobriety
under your belt you're like you know
five years of sobriety then 10 and then
you relax then it's so hard to get it
back oh yeah
you're like the fighters they got
knocked out and now you got a glass jaw
have you seen that oh yeah really hard
group to treat and and they know too
much yeah Josie's takes advantage of
that and they're always so focused on
the number of years you know instead of
just like one day at a time because that
you right they get their shame their
shame and but but the other part is they
need by the time they they often hide it
for a long time
right and so by the time they come clean
you need some serious treatment again
you gotta start over and they're like oh
no no I know I know in my home meeting
Bubba it's like no we got to start over
we need a real treatment sustained
structure here we go and it is a hard
group to treat I always ask them and I
know that it's probably the last thing
they want to talk about but like what
happened because like I want to make
sure that never happens to me so you
asked about jobs that cause relapses
relationships cause relapses yeah we're
not working with newcomers or not you
know stop going to meetings
wait just just drifting off not going do
not putting your priorities in place
yeah just it's just adrift just like
anything else we call it slowly happens
we call it working the steps in reverse
what happens yeah hey stop yeah that
praying for your your qualities to be
removed by God and then a relationship
will nothing takes out more than
relationships or and by the way some of
the times because you found somebody a
greener pink is what takes people anyway
so holy cow almost home saying is
driving me out of my mind because these
are exactly what I sort of started
waking up to it I'm like what do you
mean
people need a place to say they're all
mentally ill I was like wait a minute
and I started looking at what's going on
there and it's people I've been serving
for the last thirty years it's a drug
addicts and it's chronically mentally
ill that's it that's who's out there and
these people can be helped as you know
drug addicts it's it's a dicey er as we
all know how right I see that prospect
is but at least we can put forces in
place to push them in the right
direction as opposed to allow them just
continue using till they die which is
what's happening now three day are dying
in our streets three a day okay so new
was eaten by the time by a coyote so the
park look at saber-toothed tiger tore
somebody apart this is a tally lives in
we live in Griffith Park are these ads
torn to pieces are these stats accurate
we have a hundred and ninety thousand
homeless people living in LA we're
second to Calcutta oh that makes sense
but Calcutta it takes care of their sick
people so they no other country doesn't
take care of sick people we're allowing
see people to die on our streets yeah so
but is it okay so is it true that any
homeless person can go down six one one
yeah and get picked up right away
yep they don't want to come in they
don't want to come in I know I yeah IIIi
did a campaign where I went around and
handed out towels and they had numbers
that they call they're like yeah we know
we don't want to yeah and it's through
there either I don't I want to keep
using or I'm chronically mentally ill
and that's not comfortable they have to
be sober in order to get into something
else and they won't come what came first
the chicken or the egg right so here's
our the mental illness so here's what
happened it's fundamentally the big
problem here is the mental illness be we
change our drug laws in this state
that's why they all came here right yeah
that's what created the drug thing and
then the opiate crisis so this is the
last chapter of the opiate thing so
we've gone from pharmaceutical oral
medicine to heroin and when you use of
hair when you go to the streets that's
what happens with heroin right every
when you're as heroin ends up on the
streets and and and then we change the
drug laws and said yeah you can not just
do heroin we're not gonna hassle you you
can traffic and heroin and you can stay
as steal 900 bucks today to support your
habit you wear that yeah they made that
of non crimes you can do everyone
oh so it's on you won't get you won't
get in trouble if you go to a target now
watch
happens watch the guys walk in their
stuff their coats with stuff and walk
out just watch it it's it's everyday so
then the cuts the cut the the owners
don't call anymore cuz the cops don't do
anything so it's tough it's really crazy
so that's the drug part the other part
is in this country we used to have a
very elaborate state hospital system for
people in need custodial care humans get
chronic mental illness that need
constant care there that's unfortunately
the way human brains work there are
certain illnesses that are very serious
neurological psychiatric illnesses that
you can't you have to take care of in a
structured environment we did that for
in every state the federal government
the Constitution does not provide for
any of that so it was left to the states
well all of a sudden in the 1940s really
this guy named Robert Felix a
psychiatrist came in and he started
looking at the military and he
discovered that most like something like
thirty percent of the recruits could not
qualify for going overseas to world war
two because of neurological cognitive
and mental illness so we then we got a
big problem here so he was at welcome
not a Beltran's guy is a trained
psychiatrist but a politician and a
mover he decided he knew had a social
engineer humanity he was gonna solve all
the world's problems he got he saw in
John Kennedy the guy that could help him
do that he set up this new institution
that became the National sudha mental
health he was given wide-ranging powers
one amongst which he got the ear of John
Kennedy and pushed through something
called the Community Mental Health Act
which was designed to shut down the
state hospitals and have and have all
mental health delivered in community
mental health centers that were going to
prevent mental illness something we
don't know how to do to this day yeah
and they were he and a guy named yoli's
that follow him and a guy that brown too
followed that three guys for 30 years
controlled the national suit of mental
health control the federal government's
mental health policy none of them had
ever set foot in a hospital that took
care of chronically mentally ill and
they believed in the air in the age of
one flu of the Cuckoo's Nest that they
believed that hospitals were causing
mental illness therefore they all had to
be choked often and and closed so
hundreds of thousands of people were
coming out of these state hospitals with
provisions being made from where they
would go or how they'll be treated none
they went to the prisons this the
nursing homes and the streets and we've
done nothing to reverse that except put
a bunch of laws in place that make it
even more difficult to get to and help
these people so that's what's going on
and now because they're not that because
they have bad hygiene because bad I know
but I heard you talk as well about how
we're saying for the first time since
medieval times all medieval so so when
you let sanitation break down well I
want to know where the environmentalists
all this [ __ ] and peeing in the
street goes right into the LA River
bypasses the sewage treatment plant
60,000 people [ __ ] is going into the LA
River when it rains like this bypasses
sewage treatment sick but it's like this
city's sewage going into the ocean you
don't think that's we've had mammalian
doctors Lions yeah we have sea lions and
dolphins dying off but we're going to
straw to [ __ ] Turtles knows it's bad
okay so we've got that going on I'm
sorry well
bubonic plague with so rats have
overgrown so in because they've done
nothing with the sanitation these poor
people living in our streets rats have
just gone they just exploded we our
house here we were last summer before
last we were over run like it was
unbelievable and when that happened I
thought well we're gonna have typhus
because I've practiced in this area for
a long time and I've treated typhus many
times and why don't you see something
like that like the rodent population
explodes I thought typhus here comes
three months later typhus and we had a
massive outbreak of typhus and we still
have it going it's gonna slow down on
the winter here but I but then I started
investigating well what fall is tough
what's endemic in this area that follows
typhus well the last person a about
break in the world was in Los Angeles
when the rat population over grew
there's our seniors any oh yeah oh you
don't know what that our city alright
our cities % ye are si Anna you know you
know what more it's comedy bubonic
plague holy [ __ ]
so well that's common that's common
symptoms of bubonic plague know if you
have to be verbose you swollen glands
off pneumonia sick you guys both gonna
think you have it now yes he just surfed
in the LA River oh dude
that's the it's Salmonella and collar
itself like that you're gonna get yeah
but I got away with it yeah you're fine
so how do you how do you stop all this I
mean it's it's very simple very simple
you reverse prop 47 and you started
having drug courts again and started
pushing people into treatment that's
gonna work some of the time you motivate
addict sanatorium what's Prop 47 it's
the the 47:57 the ones that made it
legal to steal and make it legal
Switzerland legalized heroin portugal
legalized everything and it's doing
wonders for their country yeah we could
legalize everything but you've got to
take care of people that are sick you
can't they take care of people but the
war they give them something or they
give them administered heroin they're
treated like and they have to go into
therapy
once they get it yes they're like
people's lives get better they're
treated yeah treated you don't just send
them out to die on the street make
things legal and set about to die on the
street that that nobody does that
right Okun tree does that it's inhuman
it's in its bizarre - it's a think that
yes don't get mental illness they don't
get drug addiction so so you guys upset
about this so there's this this well
legalize hey see my phone there three
years and she did like she's a
sociologist she studied it for the three
years oh it's exactly what's going on
like she nailed everything she knows
exactly what's going on here
so where was legalized drug use era P so
47 needs to be revised right so so we
and we need to start getting people into
some kind of treatment some kind of
something the Lanterman Petrus short Act
which was in 1973 I think overnight
overnight we took the criteria for
treatment of mental illness from need
for care person needs care Stevo needed
care we give him care to harm to self or
other that's it this gigantic leap
there's a giant zone in between unable
to care for medical needs unable to care
for Carl unable to care for sanitation
all these other things we have to be
able to bring people into treatment if
they're unable to
managed their lives will die they will
die
so change Landsman Petrus modify 47
increase access to conservatorships
which were there's some pilot program
started in California finally and and
then in what you have that in place
enforce vagrancy laws and that's it it's
over it ends immediately so when we bill
governor and build more psychiatric
trying to get me to dude yeah my Erin go
where they keep talking about on that
alone and no because people need that
solved I just don't want to go but i but
i but i wake up every day as a doctor it
just gets into my fiber i guess so i
didn't live with it this is the you know
i passion for this group this is i
require the years in a psychiatric
hospital that place you saw we had
chronic beds we had acute beds
I saw the chronic mental illness I got
very good at treating chronic mental
illness haha we had tons of them and I
saw what could be done for them and I
know how you do that right I'm looking
at this happening and like it's no other
country on earth that allows this that's
your stat your speech okay why are they
allowed to start setting up ten I never
like five years ago I saw them have ten
since we now they do somebody's giving
them tents and then the vagrancy laws
suddenly the cops weren't able to
enforce it and then their ACL you had a
couple of decisions where they literally
couldn't touch anything to right into
the including like schizophrenic swill
start hoarding their [ __ ] and pee right
yeah that's why I belong you can't touch
that yeah Wow and then so when there's a
tent just set up smack dab in the middle
of the sidewalk where you came walked on
the sidewalk not only are they allowed
to do that but you need a warrant to
enter because that's their ten cities
just Hollywood turned into everywhere
and and this is not if they also then I
don't know dealt with the sanitation and
you know they're doing nothing nothing I
remember I remember being on Skid Row
back in 2005 yeah and I was drinking out
of friends south on seventh and spring
yeah and we would sit there and watch
from the building the cops would come
around you in gamble out speaker you
guys have five minutes to move they come
back in five minutes and just hose
everything down and they just did that
further and it's now a nice area but
they just kept doing it
in doing it every week little blocks how
was that good for for these people who
live on the street how is any of this
none of its good that is good for them
and I've started taking the position
there when people go oh this is just our
own house neighbors I may just go I'm
sorry what's your experience in treating
mental illness Oh none shut up they say
man how savers shut up shut up I you
should not be talking if you do not know
what mental illness is and how to treat
it shut the [ __ ] up
and if they keep going up your murderer
you're gonna three a day or dying
because of you you are a murderer that's
what I started saying to people I'm sick
of it you said that part of the solution
was to enforce vagrancy laws but once
you got everything in place then start
pushing people off the streets into
treatment facilities pull or do we
always have room we don't enough room
though we don't need more that's pursuit
so I have a feeling the feds are coming
I've been talking to them I talked to
Ben Carson it was really really so cool
to talk to him because it was like
almost like a handoff after being on
call you know when you come off call you
you describe the cases you're handing
off and I described you Mo's gran who
took the up got it got it got it got it
these neurosurgeon yeah you're like okay
I know I get it so when you say the feds
are coming and they're talking about
like prison camp kind of stuff no I
think what you would see is the pop-up
tents for triage to get everybody
stabilized and finalized and then then
eight the federal government has a bunch
of buildings that they could put for
chronic psychiatric beds and get people
stabilized yeah they're gonna have to
really have an operation if they're
gonna pull the trigger on that now again
I used to do like EMT work right so you
ask them you know the three or four
questions and you know times four if if
if you go up to something like if they
can't answer those questions then
they're not allowed to deny care right
right so if you went up to a mental
illness guy on the street and you asked
him about three or four questions and
they can't answer it be amazed how they
can get it together yeah
mental illness you know it affects
cognition but it's not a cognitive
disorder so their cognition can be they
can solve algebraic way you know they
could do calculus and still be saying
I'm Napoleon
I always thought why can't you just go
up to mass into three or four questions
oh what a minute questions what's your
name day is it what day is it what time
the president yeah they all do that and
that tells what different parts of your
brain are working depending on what
answers no not really that just tells
whether there's a diffuse cognitive just
a dysfunction of your disorients a time
place person and you know date that's
pretty serious yeah something something
globally is wrong do you want to
announce your run for governor on our
first podcast here if somebody wants to
talk about ready for girl talk to them
don't want to do bears have no interest
in that can people have been trying to
get me to do that my daughter's coming
in Rex come here buddy
what if you can solve that problem
that's the problem with for Los Angeles
right now that's our time gonna be but
you need state law change I mean that's
you know everything about it I am
working with some state senators I've
tried to get this right you did not I
don't have to be here yeah I don't have
to be in a position of authority to work
on this you know I mean I'm still
working on such as it is because it's
right yeah I have to I can't not it's
weird
I get up every day thinking the streets
of the city we're gonna play where but
what bothers you the most that like
drive like where do you driving like oh
my god just driving yeah I Drive
wherever I go it's everywhere everywhere
it's and I just know what it is I need
people to go people call they seem fine
to me they're just what they want read
me this magazine yesterday and there was
a big article it said Malibu's RV
problem oh yeah that's a little bit
there to their subset problems there are
people that have just from the fires no
there are people who just wanna live at
the beach yeah and they'd rather they
don't want to pay for a property they
just these oh just lived for set up a
tent all right I'm looking at the beach
and there's one mile where you're
allowed to just procure you need the
whole time and though most of those
people are not homeless they're they're
sort of squatters they just want to and
they're not dumping there's there there
waste probably right right into the
sewer right into the city right into the
river writing is P bad is P bad
I understood that it's like loaded with
pneumonia which makes it like sterile
and antiseptic
P is generally sterile unless you have
some sort of like virus or infection or
something if you had measles probably
that would not be such a good thing ah
sick lately well I I just wanna get
properly vaccinated measles I think yeah
probably
oh yeah I got revaccinated man how often
should we be getting checked out by the
doctor like just for bloodwork 36
yeah once a year no even what's the six
months no no unless really yeah you know
you shouldn't be did you do any damage
with drugs no I'm just a hypochondriac
yeah then don't go too often ever your
max max max that's it good list you're
hypertensive or something else that you
need ongoing management for no just stay
away if you come into the medical system
too often we will hurt you I'm like my
side hurt so I got a pancreatic cancer I
won't be able to sleep for like weeks
well if you need reassurance then go on
when you do but I would need reassurance
every day it's just something it's just
marry a doctor there you go be a
lifeguard we're a little gonna beat me
to really Victoria Cove yeah where did
you guard from the montage word is now
that's the bank that so the sea wall in
front of that whole Cove on the south
side of Victorians that's Lagunitas in
Victoria Blue Lagoon yeah totally yeah
that's funny is that something that was
that's still one of the greatest
speeches ever and Italy really knows
about it well now but hands swells there
and I want to think about it now like
how did I do that I was so confident the
water I can handle anything yeah that's
basically people out every day every day
every day and a lot a lot of c-spine
bladder broken necks
oh no did not did not have any major
injuries I did a resuscitation one year
but but I didn't have any major when
people get caught in a short break and
then get yeah he's working over its kind
I've had like I would do like ten year
ten c-spine's yeah Wow one guy was
really serious here all up and down
that's impressive because you know how
its Shore
so they like let it break over them and
they just scorpion can't go over the
falls we had a Japanese pole vaulter
from the Olympics oh my god it was like
oh my god I love the beach run headfirst
dive broke his c2 or whatever it was and
needed beyond breathing the rest his
life and he died from pneumonia it
happens all the time if you were a
lifeguard and you served hardcore no I
did serve our course or everything else
in the water but surfing I remember you
telling me that you did serve no he
would get barreled with by boards you
know the belly boards and it's the best
place in California yeah so so I am
someplace to Treasure Island
Yeah right think like trailer park yeah
there's a trailer park
what do you guys North County seems like
dr. dick yeah how'd you like guard for
you know I can't really two three years
yeah and it was it was the greatest
thing ever it's the greatest and I was
you know and it's so frustrating now the
shoulder and stuff like that trying to
get in too dangerous now with my
shoulder yeah he's little over here
where the Aquatic Center no no no no no
no or something I just don't do it yeah
so when you were younger did you
experiment with drugs
sure oh yeah what's your favorite uh pot
did nothing for me okay and I didn't
experience when I was in college I was I
was on a floor with a bunch of stoners
and they like couldn't believe that
somebody didn't like pot I was like oh
that was astonishing to them so you're
like notes you're doing it wrong we're
gonna show you how to do it you know
squeak Oh smoke a lot every night as
soon as you finish your homework okay
about
four days into that I started having
trouble concentrating like where I
couldn't couldn't do my calculus I
remember I couldn't I couldn't hold
thoughts and as I was calculating and
I'd scared the hell out of my brain
injured myself you [ __ ] and it was
not appealing still no matter what I
just didn't like it there's that I'll
say alcohol okay
stimulants yeah
I think the lying back in the days when
it was not addictive oh yeah from 1980
1984 there he was just not addictive
that's what the whole world decided it
was not addictive it was the weirdest
time read some like the time magazines
and stuff oh this is just a recreational
drug for people for rich people and then
it started taking people out yeah well
you know what Freud knew it was
addictive his one of his partners got
taken out by it
ah yeah the lucky thing I think for me
is I just don't have any addictive
anything oh I just don't right have that
genetic hey psychedelics no but I would
I would use them if I had like end a
life stuff like if I had end-of-life
dread the research on that was really
good psilocybin like microdose English
micro dosing an end-of-life dread yeah
that's a fatal if when what's got gets
pancreatic cancer about end-of-life
dread because that seems to affect some
people and not others that right I mean
it depends on the circumstance right if
I'm dealing 94 year old they're like
yeah I'm okay I'm ready but if you have
like if one of us were to develop a
deadly cancer would not be cool we would
have all kinds of horrible feelings
about that okay I think that there are
just certain people that just feared to
write in like my mom she was you know
and terrible disabled her quality of
life was out the window but still she
clung on to life and and really feared
death right up until the end yeah see
it's a perfect person maybe to do some
of this with because what people report
is they feel more connected to something
hold something greater than themselves
they were really connected to it and so
they don't fear
losing themselves into that but I always
feel like I had a hard time doing
psychedelics because I had a lot of
anxiety yeah me too
so that's why that's why I and by the my
starting panic attacks in college - and
I'm wonder to this day of the cannabis
did that to me
so I always freaked out when I did them
but now now then I've like worked the
steps and I feel really good about life
I'm like I wish don't - hostess I would
in but I'm like man I really wish I can
do a lot of it yeah you can't but dying
I feel like I'd be tripping out I gotta
have a bad trip later but right man one
times man told me about how he's too
distant terrified of death and I thought
man that's so crazy
the I just don't get it feel like death
being dead is the one thing that you
don't have to worry about everything
leading up to it I think of it more
about losing life well you know it's
really helped me a lot and he's gonna
laugh but but I listen to a lot of
near-death experiences oh yeah and and
it's just all peace and love on yeah but
most doctors don't like that answer of
like when they when the patient comes
back like I whatever they don't want to
hear about their near-death experience
we don't want to hear it it's just there
is something characteristic that happens
when your brain goes into that state so
you think it's all just like you were
not dead if you were dead you would not
be here you've had a near-death
experience and in that state we know
it's some interesting things happen and
the reality you know of those
experiences I don't I don't know what
about ayahuasca you feel pretty strongly
about that that you shouldn't do it why
don't you partner I have talked to
professionals that use plants for
guiding people through trauma therapies
and things convincing in what they were
telling me and had good evidence for
stuff in the right hands maybe but
generally the way it's being done these
days where is the hell at me people say
that Oh ayahuasca is great you go
through hell and this terrible like
hellish experience and then you come out
the other end and you've got your stuff
resolved and like does that sound right
to me and and whenever your brain has
changed
I'm already now I'm concerned you know
because it's something you
brain has changed and so I've seen
people their personality changes and
stuff is that your personhood changes
mm-hmm because that that's yeah I don't
care if you're a better person you're a
different person and that is that's
screwing with somebody's yes
we were we were in Fiji and like they
wanted us to do kava kava and we're like
I wish should we do it should we in the
fact that like we were talking about it
like it was like we were like I have it
probably shouldn't do it yeah okay I
forgot about that
were your recovery yeah yeah it's like
valium don't do it if everybody's doing
and having a good time that's natural
for a plan we're like well you should do
it I should like strong plants yeah hey
everybody and now that you mentioned it
I do remember it yeah like the fact that
like we're kind of weird out like
talking like this it's not a good idea
at all right you're getting getting
nervous yeah yeah should tell you
something
yeah right it's like I just did this gig
and had a big college where they asked
me to come and do a Q&A on mental health
and I showed up and I didn't think about
that was interesting I've never done
anything like this and when I showed up
it was like a lot of questions about
addiction and stuff and there I was
captain Ken they got talking program
stuff what's cool is I was at Washington
State University
okay and what the thing was though like
right when it got done I was doing a
meet and greet with like nine hundred
kids that showed up for it and I had
this thought creep into my head that
like man like you know at the end of the
day when you know like everything's all
dried up like that you know I like this
kind of thing it'd be cool to fall back
on and then I was dead terrified like oh
I just had a thought of
professionalizing recovery and like and
then I was like I never want to do
anything like this again like I wish I
didn't even do it in the first place Wow
yeah yeah I I would think about it more
as community building and not
professionalizing just sharing sharing
well then I can't get paid to do it
the thing is that god I mean I did speak
you know all kinds of places and all
kinds of surgery
trouble doing comedy at schools or
anything are you doing that I have it's
crazy because there's a new tour that
I'm doing is so so explicit like for an
institution of higher learning to pay me
to bring this filth to them is just
there's something deeply wrong with that
they were like they didn't want you to
bring Wendy onstage right it's like you
you might have a problem with me
bringing a service dog onstage but
you're allowing me to air have you guys
seen what we're putting on there you
know about the one where I went
skydiving videos routinely due to
multimedia to show that ideas it's so so
they were cool that but bringing a
service dog some people might get
offended because of PETA in the audience
my dog Wendy yeah it's a lot backwards
but I don't think that was the
Washington State is that if people have
anxiety or OCD or triggers and phobias
the way that's managed is with exposure
right composure therapy not withdraw the
exposure and never be around the
stimulus Oh getting exposed to the sting
goes right we expand our comfort zone by
getting out of it yes so now I like
Howie Mandel with his notorious or
germaphobe you know that's the worst
thing to be to avoid germs Yeah right
like you can't I mean when I'm doing my
meet and greets after my show isn't like
with like the 900s we are and I'm shake
every hand I'm think to myself like
shaking hundreds of hands all
back-to-back is probably so good for me
because I'm keeping my immune system on
its toes there there is some called the
sewer rat theory of yeah you know em you
know agendas you me know Jenna city but
wash your hands right that water okay
there's this this I went on a school
field trip in eighth grade I was
attending school at the American School
in London we were very
privileged school yes you know I was
very very privileged upbringing and we
went on a school field trip to Egypt
like for a week oh yeah yeah and and
they said don't drink the tap water
don't even let anybody put ice cubes in
your soda oh and I've watched this guy
Duncan's toothbrush in the Nile River
and sit there brushing his teeth and I
thought wait a second if tap water is so
bad then what's the Nile and here's this
guy's fine I thought man that guy
brushing his teeth in the Nile if he
went to England where I live and drank
tap water
he might get sick from that just
whatever we expose ourselves to we'd
become okay so I thought in my mind
right there 13 years old eighth graders
like man you know probably the
healthiest thing I could do is travel
the entire world over and just drink tap
water everywhere I go and I went on to
do precisely that I think we were very
lucky man with wild boys like like as we
went to every continent except
Antarctica where I presume the waters
very pure yeah everywhere else and said
put down my bags and I would brush my
teeth I mean I did get kind of sick in
Kenya but I don't and they would give us
malaria pills and malaria pills would
would cause me to have like terrible
nightmares
oh sure so I would throw out the malaria
pills and then use the actual bottle
that came in to fill up with like xanax
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you could live to have this podcast
yeah it's good yeah yeah it's a good one
I I hope so best one we've ever done I
was you know I was looking at my watch
truthfully you think man do we have like
enough that we can really pair it you
know to make it great make it like
really great I I'll pick up the the
clips that get listen tulsi gabbard on
there I like that one with John well
next so good and
or Jordan Peterson times are very
interesting conversation Jordan
Peterson's the super controversial dude
some people yeah beliefs on on
transgender stuff is that the guy he
just he just he says stuff that gets me
trouble okay but has he really seen
anything that that's bad no he's talking
about what his experiences as a clinical
psychologist you know what he you know
he's like a scientist and I found him
years before anybody else did he was
used to this series called maps of
meaning and I'm always looking for guys
that pull together psychology and
anthropology and that's kind of what he
was doing I so I got very interested in
him and then he got embroiled in this
controversy where the the district he
was in in Canada started mandating
preferred gender pronouns and was
essentially saying you if you don't even
if somebody changes their preferred
pronoun every 10 minutes and you get it
wrong you've broken the law and he took
that that's pretty easy to write the
reason after that's because that's it's
in his opinion how things led to that
what was called the Gulag Archipelago so
and so then he got very political all of
a sudden I was just like I cracked a
smile because I was thinking about like
these memes where it's like you know
thirty year old man who identifies as a
six year old just broke a record and
t-ball motorcyclist who identifies as a
bicyclist just shattered the record yeah
those are great
I love reposting those I know and going
through some interesting it's definitely
yeah it'll work itself out though it
always does I guess maybe it's just it
really it feels so alien so different
man I'm just glad that I had that I'm
not the dude who is on Loveline with you
in the early 2000s or mid 2000s in this
day and age yeah you know I like this
nothing not that I necessarily was ever
really mean-spirited or no you know but
you could get misconstrue and you were
loaded hoon oh my god I was
yeah me too Steve oh yeah right uh you
know what I did that was I had this old
tattoo of a guy humping a baby when well
I was 2006 that I got it and immediately
I recognized how awful it was and I
blogged out the the baby who was a hero
and then I and then I turned into the
blob into an ostrich and then I burned
it all off and then I got him riding a
motorcycle oh yeah okay oh my god and
then but the thing was that like 20 17
20 and 18 like all these years later
then that comes up and people are like
trying to like tear me down like ah this
terrible from that tattoo yeah like 13
years it's crazy
12 me 12 years after I got the tattoo no
it's been a while there there's just
there was an organized concerted effort
to just ruin me over a tattoo I got a
long time ago it's that weird that
people are that kind of energy right and
it's like okay you know like that I
became a tattoo artist what I did I just
did I'm gonna show you my portfolio your
video of you doing something to somebody
one point ah this is now look at this is
easy with the art and then oh it's
pretty big been a lot better yeah uh-huh
that's you I did that yeah I did all
these whoa like that my girl Wendy Wow
and then I did this one last night I'm
him
Jesus riding a dinosaur how'd you do
that
alright did you do that freehand no no
you didn't create a stencil and then
okay alright okay
yeah that's great well thanks man that's
the other thing I'm looking at this this
is I swear I was with you once when you
did we did it I mean I'm not even
surprised that that would have come up
at some point yeah I can't remember what
you're doing but it was that you were
writing like letters on somebody's right
oh that's right
you're like yo mama's name and I wasn't
wearing gloves yeah that's what it was
and then I got the idea from when that
happened I said you know what I'm gonna
make a video of just giving awful
tattoos but I'll try really hard and
it's turned into this roaring gloves
every time too I'm doing a real
apprenticeship with the super pro guy
named Mike Santa Fe Wow yeah and as I
said it rented this to see how it feels
doing a podcast but also to see how it
feels as a traveling tattoo shop very
good idea yeah I was sitting right in
that seat there when I gave him the
dinosaur tattoo last night that's it
that's the best spot for me to work
because of the skin is very tight yeah
we can raise money for the animal
sanctuary right it's it's pretty
exciting man and the way the the
tattooing works you take an online class
go in it's like the Health Department
you take a test they licensed here as a
professional tattoo artist but your
license has to be tied to one specific
shop you can't just go rogue like if you
get a liquor license you can only sell
it in the shop it can be a shop so
that's like can you go state to state no
probably yeah what kind of a business
license you get it I don't know find out
that's cool I'm just checking it out how
many tattoos have you done I mean almost
countless if you count over the years
like just people this year this year uh
I did yo momma's name I did the Satanic
temple tattoo then I did the tribal
[ __ ] stamp then I did but man then
Takashi then Wendy yeah there Wendy and
then the banana dick and then did you
dinosaur no I did not invent I mean I've
done eight tattoos this year not bad
yeah it's exciting
demon do you want a tattoo do you have
any yeah you want one really what if I
do if I start to go down that road
you're
if his dad is in his 70s getting all
tatted up well yeah I don't like 65 it
does start to your your skin ages it
does start to bug you like for some
pretty god it's correct yeah what up
with ink he went to Japan and easily you
always wanted to get a tattoo so I got
one then he came back and then he just
went apeshit
okay she's driving a motorcycle all over
the place how old is he he born in 44
Wow see same age is my dad yeah we're
selling the same guy 45 45 yeah my dad
75 yeah well your mom still wrong yeah
Mary uh-huh
my mom works here in Pasadena for uh dr.
O'Toole the plastic surgeon yeah yeah
yeah she's been with him for like 20
years when he was at Santa Teresita and
then I grew up in Pasadena no she just
helps that was all the way that admin
stuff okay and then and then I grew up
in Pasadena then my parents split and my
mom went to Glendora my dad went to
Carlsbad so did you go to school here
yeah I went to Temple City High School
you know when he said about people who
think that they've got the homeless
crisis figured out and he said do you
understand mental illness Ben shut up
yes how about the people who do
understand mental illness that are
actually psychiatrists just throwing
medication at people throwing medication
yeah jazz like that one guy we know yeah
I'm not super into lots of medication
but when people have serious mental
illness are dying on the street it's
helpful okay part of the deal okay yes
I'm not as you know I like that like the
more holistic meds where it's necessary
and then we're not to the psychology but
were you on like ADHD medication as a
kid my parents wanted me to be on it and
they tried to bring me in and the no
doctor would go for it well when I was
crying on an airplane like wouldn't even
have my mom would like feed me alcohol
like as a baby
you really the doctors want to put me on
ADHD and my mom was like no way
it was the other way around for me my
parents wanted me on it the dollars
wouldn't go Moorhead that's funny yeah
oh all right well what do you think man
do you think that's a podcast I think
it's a podcast I got awesome at a good
time okay having a good time
hey thank you so much drew dude
congratulations my privilege I'm private
don't you just let this thing fly put it
out there let there we'll do with it
what it will man what a great guy and
that's exactly what I'm doing it's just
putting it out there
we only shaved off like two or three
minutes I think
oh man and so for everybody listening
still who's hung through the entire
podcast last time I said please hit me
up on Twitter and I put a like on every
single tweet where people have responded
to it a lot of people said they don't
have Twitter and other spaces but here's
what I want you to do I'm so grateful to
all of you if you follow me on Instagram
go ahead and tag me in a post like
something to do with this show and
actually tag me don't just put my handle
in the comment cuz I won't see that it's
where you click tag photo and put the
thing because I have a whole feed for
that and I will like every single post
that you know that says that you listen
to the whole [ __ ] thing you know tell
me what you think and give me any credit
criticism that I you know that whatever
you think I can do better but man I'm
just excited about this so dudes like
all of you listening watching like you
have already made this show a hit-and
man I can't thank you enough
so we'll see you next week and we're out
of like store it up stuff it's gonna be
like [ __ ] zoom Skype whatever [ __ ]
but we're gonna get some heavy hitters
so it's on thank you so much guys look